yeah welcome to this video and we all
moved 12 of a 15-minute game and
something round happened to him I
started to to hit I started to do my
comments before him before i started the
video so actually a couple of minutes of
my comments are gone and so let's see
what what's yeah we've got a king's
indian come to do it it all started from
some of different move order from a from
an old Indian move order and we came to
this typical position I can um look
briefly at the the opening moves after
after the game so on
yeah of course i'm preparing before and
i should i should play this as soon as
possible need to get something going on
the queenside a big difference to the
classical king's indian with short
castling here as it is normally played
um is that in this position on he's got
we are tonight's d7 on and on on on 86cm
so i play just queen a3 intending c5 and
he's far away from playing g4g for i can
just take my threat now SC 5 and he must
must prevent the smooth in some way not
sure that he can one more firm probably
not working as b6 after which i may be
just tengo c5 not 100 potential apple
this is a passive approach okay he
probably intends to play a G fri which
as of course I'm about the only play
that down is left for black so c5 now or
something else yeah b5 yeah be 595
winning a porn is Sam is really bad for
what shouldn't do that I can go see 5 g
four and then what next is he
threatening g3
should I spend one move to play h3 yeah
I'm not so familiar with them these
positions I often play other position
types against the Kings Indian I'm not
so sure about for example the Moose age
3 year this is a good in this position
c5 g4 he might play g3 next and get
somewhere
yeah stop come on let's play c5 it's at
our to calculate if you should invest
someone move to to make it more
difficult to place afore on age three I
think he would have played whoo sorry on
h3 he would have played g4 anyway
sacrifice a pawn to get night Bishop to
age four and it's not it's not clear to
me if this video would have been
beneficial c5 was just just a quick a
move if he goes gee for now which is
pretty much the only idea that I'm
seeing at least um the question is how
do I continue my night see for
pressurizing d6 or maybe em pawn to c6
this also um can be can be good I said
um as it tries to to kill the night on
b8 his next move will be g three any way
to learn to sacrifice
sacrifice a pawn to to get some play
yeah takes should I take on d6 mean one
thing if i take on d6 play Knight c4 and
he goes bishop aight i can i can think
about bishop to to be six really this
could be an idea ok let's take this
now this move pin so that rg3 I can play
Bishop to b6 if it takes on h2o probably
just clicking edge one
yeah this is a fairly typical position
where why does some yeah actually let's
let's let's describe it in some other
way if you would give this position to a
computer for white it would win
absolutely all games because some
objectively white is probably winning
the only thing that can happen is you
get you can get made it because you
overlooked some some some tricks final
attack um yeah attacking them ideas that
like might come up with objectively this
is probably just over simply those
pieces the night on a six-night obviate
they're hard to way far too much away
from the King side to help in the tech
and it just just not enough pieces on
that taking side and that maybe just
threatening a v5p 595 night XD six and
and that's it
yeah I think g3 you must play g3
everything else looks by far too slow
black cannot play let's say what takes
on a three or something this is just uh
just lost probably g3 is the way to go
maybe Bishop to h4 can be considered
maybe
but the Sun probably will get answered
burner by Bishop to b6 also
yeah but should be six was my intention
the bishop move actually has got one
very direct idea Bishop to g3 and Queen
to h4 this is some this is also fairly
fairly common this idea so Bishop to b6
how to continue or its own do I have
some some other some other idea but take
on edge for a queen takes 90 86 so so
simplest of course but Jenny plays g3
and I'm probably losing fruit because of
g3 h3 Bishop h3n terminal defense it
doesn't really help that I took 36 porn
I don't really want to take but this
Bishop to GM three years of course I'm
and I attacking IDM but should be six
Queen to e7 let's say b5 push-up g3 I
can take on d6 with the Queen iam this
is really a really a lot but so let's
say we should be six Queen to g5 maybe
b5 push-up g3 mmmm now I don't like it I
don't really like it so I could also
play pawn to g3 but it's not only two
attractive is he threatening something
you are taking and playing g3 Alice's
this is a threat
so be five you take the left one plays
Knight c5 this is this is complete
completely out of this world it's really
bad
okay I want to keep this space thing
come this is better than then taking on
on h4 so Queen g5 probably Queenie 7i
think I can play b6 this should be it
should be good enough greenies have will
be 55 in p5 d success is hanging with
the Queen also
so probably I needs to go 25 and then
after 96 play Bishop to g3 can it is
dangerous
yeah Bishop d3
how do I am how do I go about that if I
go this is this an idea okay Bishop d3
takes pawn tags and then he threatening
Queen to h4 d5 push-up g3d tags tags
queen to d6 and Queen to h4 I can play
take a g6 and it's a draw
yeah this is getting very very spooky
the third position and yeah I never feel
too comfortable in those positions where
like it text me even if it is completely
winning which is probably the case but
he always like always has got some play
so my intention now is Bishop g3 takes
takes Queen d6 not the night 26 so then
on Queen to h4 that would be Queen g 6
a-6 and at least a draw
yep and his threat is Queen to h4 now
and also this is some this is even
stronger taking on on h2 this is far
more dangerous even taking on edge to
King takes Queen h4 check Queen g1 a
king g one g three and checkmate it's
not made it isn't even made
it's not made I've got Bishop g1 after
rook news
this is Bishop h3 and stuff like that
so I'm hoping for this Queen g6 counter
plane
there's also the question if if I can
play rook rook somewhere do you want b
ball or something and then Bishop g1 but
i think it's not possible for example
after taking takes on edge to King takes
Queen check king g one g three at dinner
brooke move so that Queen h2 checking of
one queen h1 check I've got Bishop g1
all the way back from v6 yeah maybe but
then it looks very very dangerous like
there's some other moves probe possible
hmm very very tricky I think you should
take on edge to King takes Queen edge
for check g3 looks um well be born maybe
and then I don't know Queen edge to
maybe it's not working at all Queen edge
to king of one Queen h1 bishop g one
cannot even play Bishop h3 at the end as
I take to g6 will check Queen g6 King
edge at Queen h5 Queen DJ three very
deep line okay instead of taking on edge
to it can also think about Queen to h4
now aha something else
maybe tend intending to to grab on be
sick son also he find if I was hanging
of course but it's still others drawn I
mean with Queen to g6 so I can think
about just just about taking
the other thing I'm asked I'm not sure
if I wait wait wait wait what if I I
just take on reform I've got Queen e6
check and queen takes d4 shouldn't this
be good ok now when if i take here then
it can take on b6 first night be 6 9 p-6
taken on reform we take seven then
there's always also straws come on if
you just turn recaptures I can play
Queen e6 check and 20 x g 4n this look
so really bleak for black
it takes b6 and we capture with the
night okay so then let's go grab the
pawn and also this is the kind of
position I see see night XP 6 it's a
tactic from a technical point of view
tricky but of course he's got g3 hanging
so um let's say kings and then then
Queen takes g4 Queen takes d4 and
probably needs to exchange on g4 Bishop
takes g-form Bishop Knight takes b6 I
can just re capture g3 is hanging and so
on so come on take it so should be
should be really good now he must kept
he must exchange and now he's got g3
hang as well so takes here
and now after taking lasix I'm
threatening ace have been promoting so
this is basically a double attack 87 a
double threat if you want to put it this
way a seven threatens to promote and
this was hanging so here and you can I
think just go here to win even more
material I ate Queen the Sun it's not so
that's not able to prevent it
yeah but I can just take this Bishop
right why not yeah one of the rare cases
were actually managed to win such a
position I tend to get made it even in
the most winning types of position in
the Kings Indian classical yeah we had
to let's just look back here I mean the
third the comments that I did God lost
because I didn't didn't press the button
um okay yeah well this is the old Indian
the day exchange I can I can go all the
way back and do a quick recap the
exchange here doesn't give white really
much this kind of stuff black plays f6
let's say here f6 something like this
and why it has nothing King us fine on
c7 okay so 93-97 here black of course
can also play Bishop e7 and stay within
the old Indian but this transpose to
kings in yet defense now and here I
think black should seriously consider
bishop am Knight to g4 simply attacking
this bishop and probably something like
this will happen
and blacks got got counterplay something
like this and so on so here he went 95
and I don't like this too much because
this is the ideal wide set up these
nights are protecting the center and the
bishops are on the best squares
especially the e3 bishop quite often you
have this back on c1 where it doesn't do
so much it here it has got this stag and
also we have from this where white is
intending to go with before the instant
I'm a three of course white must
consider this this isn't so clear
actually if it is grateful black but you
don't want that b3 yeah and maybe here
it's um it's one point where black as
chance to improve this this is very
unlikely to succeed in this position
because you have the the nights on the
queenside and they're not on e 7 g 6 f 6
and so on so this firepower you need on
the King cytisus off on the queenside
and you even gained against time on
those pieces yeah i was i was unsure
Queenie won his son and I know if this
best move he intends this with an
exchange on activation of this miss
piece the problem is in general if I
played something like this for example
here here but can't play the smooth and
this can be a very very annoying it
looks like very I don't know it like it
doesn't lead to much but it's dangerous
just have a look for example this kind
of stuff I cannot go h3 because of the
sacrifices and gets its
it's very simple how do you defend this
it's it in a practical game it's not
easy it is probably good for white but
not sure how for so this prevents
pressured match for all together and now
we switch back to this g5 plan ITA this
is really a good Kings Indian those
those nights are not well placed and he
is not quick on the King side yeah here
we are back in this number the saurian
in the part of the game way I actually
was able to do a comentary yeah thanks
for watching this game hope it was
enjoyable